ten bears 50 bands 100 bands  she's not even discussing I'm way up I  feel blessed  I'm so I'm so I'm so I'm so I'm so prior  you  running through the six started from the  bottom now we're here started from the  bottom  both teams you  nice you want a photo you already know -  you only live once Yolo I had somebody  told me I fell off  I bet you needed that  erry day erry day sitting on the bench  will really play she caused me to  referee because I'm so efficient my ex  asked me where you moving I said want  some better things  don't Michael Jordan still has his hoop  earring here I get boxes  a free George like I play for North  Carolina I like all my asses with two  lines  Juden  what am i doing what am i doing oh yeah  that's right  I'm doing me  I live for this  it's not just a hobby like that  that's you more photo you already know  you only award tomorrow  oh yeah